cam Thomas around a nice screen from
Claxton gets the roll off the window
shot clock down to two Thomas races in
and reverses it home
the team can up and trade a player that
is loved and revered and it's just like
hey this
deer as you see the hand one there by
cam Thomas
swings it out gets it back fires away
knocks it down puts the foul and a
chance for four for Camp Thomas cam
Thomas is a tough person to guard you
can't one you should never go under on
cam Thomas and that was the mistake once
he recognized he went under on a shooter
he over exaggerated the correction
here's Thomas weaving fishing
[Music]
[Applause]
you're even okay with giving away a
couple of possessions trying to get that
fifth out because that's six thousand
because you know the game would be
completely different once it happens
O'Neal comes up with a swipe
ahead of the field toughness ties it
with a slam this is the second one but
great defense here in transition throws
the ball ahead cam Thomas with the
finish one point shy of his career high
Thomas
three to shoot Thomas will take
[Applause]
117-116. Thomas plays it in with the
left hand
39. and have plenty of time to do so on
this possession
Henry and effective if had nine lead
changes in the last three minutes
[Music]
Thomas cut off gets it back from Claxton
shot clock is winding down Thomas has to
hoist had hit cam Thomas drills the tray
cam Thomas right smack in the middle of
both of those well what we've learned
about Camp Thomas since the time he put
on a Brooklyn Nets uniform he wants the
ball in clutch moments Thomas the
rainbow jumper goes and a foul but look
right here just sizing up the tomb
couple dribbles knocked down the
three-point shot so far in this season
he's shooting 40 from the three-point
line and that was an area you looked at
Thomas on the switch now has Florence
Thomas drives in Banker
wow cam Thomas has got the touch well
has he there stop and go across and over
and does a nice job hanging it and
that's where you see Paul George
stepping up a lot of clean looks for
Paul George here in the early part of
this third quarter roll to the rim
Claxton finishes on a setup by Thomas
that's what Royale was talking about
take a look at this role in a nice job
by cam Thomas when he's got two on them
Eagles there's Eagles in in all lands
west coast East Coast Brooklyn L.A
Thomas locks it up
[Applause]
Edmund Sumner the Sumner slam
by Thomas and Sumner coming from the
weak side throwing it down
some nice Push by Brooklyn
up ahead Sumner race to the rim Sumner
gets there what a French rejection but
it's Thomas with the jam
challenges
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah he is a killer
the next Trail by one
four and a half to go out of the timeout
Thomas over pal he's fouled connects and
a chance for three
Camp Thomas can match his point total
from Saturday night with a made free
throw there's a lot of impressive things
with how cam Thomas scores but we often
see him